but the headline here is that the white
supremacy in the biden white house is so
intense
21 black staffers can there be more than
21 total
not a huge staff at the white house 21
black staffers have fled
speaking of the new jim crow candace
owens is the founder of the charity
blexit she's probably not surprised by
this she joins us tonight candace are
you surprised that the racism the white
supremacy
at the white house is so intense that
black staffers are fleeing for their
lives
i have to say i'm a little bit upset
that i'm not involved in these strategy
sessions at the white house i just
picture them all sitting around a table
and just quick quick black people are
waking up and they're not happy grab me
an asian and put them in front of the
podium we've got to shift here and shift
gears completely on the pr strategy i
mean this is this is actually what
they're doing right because black
americans first and foremost what's
happening parallel to this is black
americans are waking up the lie that was
black lives matter so at the same time
you're having these black americans that
were quite literally just given these
positions they weren't meant to do
anything they never wanted them to
actually do anything they probably were
under qualified for the positions that
they even had but the idea was oh look
we're getting on our niece literally if
you're nancy pelosi to the black lives
matter narrative right remember she did
that that notorious bow and got down on
one knee and we're gonna do this and
show you that we're gonna hire a bunch
of black people but we don't actually
care what they think we just need them
to be sit there and be black now the
black americans in the white house are
waking up and going you know what that's
not okay with me and they're frantically
searching to find up drum up a new
narrative of hate and this one's going
to be asian-american asian lives matter
quick grab me k-pop and hopefully
america is going to fall for this when
in reality we're focused on the gas
prices the inflation prices and it's
just an absolute complete joke
is there anything more destructive than
white liberal guilt it feels like it's
hurt more people than nuclear weapons
it really has and and people are
starting to see that even patrice colors
right but the person who started black
lives matters basically said well it's
not my fault that you guys gave me your
white guilty dollars and i lied about
what i did with it and bought myself an
entire real estate empire and that's the
truth so it's not just black americans
that need to have an awakening it's
white americans you know you have to
stop allowing people to manipulate you
emotionally and tell you that you're a
bad person just because you're born a
certain color and hopefully we're going
to start to see that as we head into
this election cycle
people hate themselves are not good
leaders
weak men and unhappy women i agree with
the democratic party hinnis absolutely
neither one of them great to see you
tonight thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight